hey guys dr. Burke here I want to talk
about second skin collagen in digestion
there's many different aspects of
collagen I'm going to talk about the
digestive angle first of all what is
collagen collagen comes from the Latin
word which means glue it's the stuff
that holds everything together and yes
your hair is made of collagen your nails
your skin your muscles but there's a lot
of fascia which is connective tissue
around the organs around the muscles
that hold everything in and protect
everything nice and tight you know even
keeps the muscles separated the tendons
the ligaments the arteries are made from
collagen your eyes have collagen the
fluid inside the eyes are have a lot of
collagen your blood cells have collagen
65% of your bodies collagen but here's
what I'm finding out with a lot of
people they're they're getting older and
their collagen is kind of falling apart
prematurely and that is because I found
an interesting connection between the
digestion see when you actually eat
collagen or eat protein your body
supposed to turn the protein into
collagen but it takes a really acidic
stomach to convert that process so
normally your stomach should be between
one and three the pH being really really
acid neutral is 7 when you go lower it's
acid you need like 1 2 3 so what's
interesting is that when you're 20 years
old you have a certain amount of acid in
your stomach okay as you age 30 40 50 60
70 s look what happens the pH of your
stomach goes down and down and you lose
the stomach acids so when you're aged
between 60 and 70 you basically have 25%
of the acid that you had when you're 20
now this is a huge connection that no
one's talking about because if you can't
digest that collagen the tissues become
rigid you lose like elasticity you get
high blood pressure everything start
sagging inside and out so so that's
interesting so what happens the pH in
the stomach is the thing
that triggers the enzymes the protein
enzymes very powerful to be able to
break down the food turn it into
collagen so here's what I would
recommend you do if you have any type of
collagen issues and digestive issues fix
the digestion because then you'll start
to absorb it versus trying to consume
collagen from some you know powder
because you're not going to digest it
anyway
fix the digestion and then see if you
can't pull it in from the food there's
many different collagen products out
there and there's I'll do a video on
that but the point is that if your
stomach is not good you're not going to
pull it in
outside the vinegar with each meal very
very important
take some acidifier betaine how to
chloride there's different things you
can take the eat your stomach acid the
other thing is if your pH is too
alkaline
you have to realize it's going to take a
little time to build that back up it's
not a matter of just drinking one glass
of diluted episode of vinegar and then
everything's fine it's going to take
months and months to build it up because
your pH is taken a long time to
disappear to the point where you don't
have that acidifies anymore in summary
if your digestion is not good focus on
that and you're going to see some great
changes thanks for watching hey guys
thank you so much for watching I really
appreciate it
please click the share button below and
I will see you in the next video